a columbus police officer who killed an
unarmed black man
is sidelined this morning and the city's
mayor says the officer
should be fired officials released video
of the incident that sparked outrage in
the community
officer adam coy did not turn on his
body cam until
after tuesday's shooting the silent
video shows the dead man
47 year old andre hill holding only a
cell phone
jeff begays has a story and we warn you
the video we're about to show you
is disturbing body cam footage from
officer adam coy
shows him approaching an open garage
andre hill is inside
and walks toward the officer with a cell
phone in his left hand
his other hand is not visible within
seconds officer coy
shoots and hill collapses all this was
captured via the body cam's pre-record
function
60 seconds of video without audio
it's at this point that coy turned on
his camera put your
hands out to the side hands out to the
side now
he'll lay for more than six minutes
without aid
a violation of police policy he was
later pronounced dead at the hospital
to see him lying in the driveway
minute after minute after minute
with no attempt to render aid
and that is a stunning disregard
for life and in this case black life
it all began when a neighbor called
police early tuesday to report a
suspicious vehicle
allegedly repeatedly being turned on and
off
a non-emergency call according to
investigators no
weapon was recovered at the scene the
mayor says
hill was a guest at the home a review of
officer coy's personnel file
shows more than three dozen complaints
filed against him since 2002
including use of force all but a few
were marked
unfounded or not sustained it's not
clear from the files of any sustained
complaints involved use of force
following hill's shooting coy has been
relieved of his duties in order to turn
in his badge and gun
while the investigation continues hill's
sister shauna barnett
shared her thoughts online my brother
was snatched away from me
now i and my family will be there for
him
and other murdered victims to take up
this plight that our culture has
painfully endured for years for cbs this
morning
jeff begays in washington
the columbus police chief calls the
incident a tragedy and promises that any
officers who violated laws or policies
will be held
accountable this is the second fatal
police shooting in columbus this month
on december 4 casey goodson jr was shot
in the back
as he was entering his home somebody
will have to one day explain to me
how an officer with three dozen
complaints including use of force can
still be patrolling
the streets it's a really disturbing
question no help for six minutes